polpetta sfigato attento mai dimenticato
che noi dobbiamo la scarpata
bastava che lui doveva trovare che se
avesse nascosto qui siccome cup e non
sia il suo cappello preferito se avete
dei nostri altri video di among sullo
stendino sapete che questo è il suo
cappello preferito il basso con i fiori
sono scuse assieme a voi questa volta
non nella vita reale
nel videogioco che avete in soli altri
vito abbiamo giocato a nascondino nella
vita reale among us mi sono piaciuti un
sacco se non li avete visti dopo
quest'estate vederli comunque come
funziona vi diciamo bello si stimavano
l'impostore dovrà cercare gli altri crew
mail s ii trova lì deve eliminare invece
crew metz devono nascondersi quindi un
bel proprio nascondino devono
nascondersi e cercare di non essere
erogati dall impostore che ritrova li
elimina subito però all'inizio si saprà
chi è l'impostore medi se saprà da chi
si deve scappare il più non si può
votare l'impostore siccome sappiamo già
chi eri impostare all'inizio è il nostro
obiettivo e scappare dall impasto
renault si può votare in quanti noi ci
possono essere emergency meeting cene
sarà solo uno all'inizio cui annunceremo
chi è
l'impostore in più le luci saranno basse
al minimo per tutti quanti sia per il
fiume hits che parli imposto reati sarà
ancora più difficile gara troppo
divertente non vedo l'ora d'iniziare
volete un altro
lei aste ma poi lasciate un bel mi piace
su questo video raggiunge i 10 mila mi
piace ne faremo un altro anzi
consigliate sicure tutte le modalità qua
sotto nei commenti
prendete hip hop mettetevi comodi e
iniziamo il game è psico abbiamo
ricordato le regole in chat ma ho messo
la regola completa su instagram
infatti se volete giocare assieme a noi
seguitemi su instagram il nome anita
stokes ed è nelle storie che metto il
codice per giocare assieme iniziamo
subito lo partito allora io sono più
mail anzi io quindi dobbiamo scappare ma
prima di tutto dobbiamo chiamare le
emergenze meeting ok allora l'impostore
è il verde capiamo che l'impostore è il
verde scuro quindi dobbiamo scappare
sapete verde scuro mi viene un importa
adesso anche lui chiumente dobbiamo fare
le nostre tasse
la mia tatto preferita dobbiamo in più
dobbiamo nasconderci aiuto se qualcuno
meno c'è scritto impostare basten in
aiuto dove mi nascondo 2000 scondo
allora io mi nascondo qua io ho già
fatto o no no sono già notato un corpo
hanno riparato il corpo praticamente si
possono comunque riportare i corpi così
noi ti lumetti guadagniamo tempo per
fare poi le tasche nascondersi aiuto
aiuto aiuto scuro giusto con la visione
così viene ancora davvero un sacco di
ansia in questa modalità ancora più
paura no ma dove si sostituiva tutti qua
vicino al reattore incontrati già un
paio dai dobbiamo fare l'età io ho quasi
finito di fare mio tasto sa bene forte e
allora pensavo nel crew medio delle
imposte si deve sbrigare severe di
eliminarsi
ok si trova pastore
secondo me si stanno vediamo le camere
non c'è nessuno sono tutti nascosti
bravi io ho finito le mie passioni
eccolo vedo che ti arrivando poi mi
dovevo rispondere il trasponder dove vi
nascondo blue note blu e safe allora
devo andare in elettrico
no eliminato un'altra persona o no sarà
eliminato un altro dei nostri
io no e 74 all share lo schifo lo
skipper e io no
no abbiamo perso ma abbiamo quindi siamo
rimasti 1 2 3 4 6 e siamo rimasti in
cinque siamo rimasti in pochi scrive blu
aiuto che insegue verde ho preso una
vendita ho preso un po dov'è andata si
sia qui in security tool è finita da
tasca perché tu sei fantasmi nuovo tg
allora ho visto mi dove mi manca solo
una tazza se celeste che si nasconde
dietro uno dei motori
sembra tutto tranquillo qua attenta
weapon questo no ma io devo andarci ma
poi l'ha passato ma mai inventando
giusta
vai dovrebbe seguendo la catastrofe
ho finito le task ora vado noto oberdan
mancano pochissime tasca mi nascondo
no qua è troppo pericoloso potrebbe
trovarmi subito in electric
ok allora io mi nascondo qua vediamolo
scaricando gli altri proventi finiscano
le tasche
ok forse un bellissimo destro di cosa
che sta avvenendo proprio lire
no no no per rubare il nascondiglio
rosso se si trova entrambi probabilmente
vedrai barbanera dai dati che volevo
l'impostore speriamo che krivets prima
finale tasti così forse possiamo farcela
bene siamo fantasmini allora seguiamo
l'imposta vediamo sta seguendo rossoblù
la sua visibilità ovviamente diminuita
come quella dei cream esiste quindi non
so se riesci a vedere esattamente dove
sta andando e rossi
ma chi manca da eliminare forse vincerà
reimpostare mamma con un velocissimo 30
gol
mancano pochissime pasqua bravissimo lui
invece che stanno il motore di sopra
frasi che vi nascondete bene non andate
in giro altro no
rimangono solo in tre ce la faranno
manca solo uno o due testi deve stare
dai crumetti io credo in voi torres
memini potete farcela allora seguiamo la
verde e come mai nato eccolo eccolo si
sta cercando qualcuno nascosto e si noi
eletti che non c è messo dai finito nei
taschini mancano pochi prima ma infatti
non mancherà al massimo 12
comunque devo dire che questo impostare
fatto bravi si sta benissimo
siete davvero troppo bravi terra si è
nascosto anche se fantasma si trattava
bene vai viola scappa non lo trovo più
che sta seguendo viola che velocità
arrivare a sta curando le camere
sicuramente ha finito le tasche da fare
c'è qualcuno che non ha finito le tacche
da voi vi ritenete anche vinciamo io
vedo b ora colacone in giro qui sono
security viole più a rischio perché sta
girando però così c'è più rischio klim
postale si trova invece rimanendo
nascosto può non trovare esatto dobrus
40 le camere lo stesso chi è che non ho
finito la cas capita però che non lo
trovo più l'imposta resina scotta anche
lui si è nascosto per spiare bene
qualche popolo magari
no di una sassaiola riesce sempre
bravissimo perché non trovi blu qua c'è
sempre quante ma quando sta inseguendo
verde sta inseguendo ancora viola colore
la visibilità diminuito per noi lo
stiamo per prendere impostare sta
impazzendo perché non riesce in un ruolo
e blu che la squadra stesso benissimo
tempo stai dover diventare ristrutturano
scotti gli ultimi clienti da eliminare e
come ha visto celeste ha visto celeste
basta volerlo o nota che vincerà un
impostore
ovviamente quando rimangono pochi più
mette ancora più di falsi lei nascondino
paolo di jimi ce la faranno i nostri
eroi cerette adatto per fesso altro ha
vinto l'impostore perché ha trovato blu
ma c'è un problema perché il server via
disconnesso purtroppo l'altro server a
crashato ogni tanto succede non capisco
il perchè e devo subito cancellare la
storia sanità graham rimase l'altro il
nuovo codice perché so che questi teli
aspettando che dite che lo stesso ora
eccoci qua
nella scorsa ha vinto l'impostore perché
ha trovato tutti persino blu che ha
nascosto benissimo prossima partita
bene allora sappiamo che l'impostore è
viola quindi no al ribaltone ha già
eliminato qualcuno bene l'impostore
viola hanno visto l'ha visto chi ha già
eliminato
sarebbe quindi sbrighiamoci per fare
nostra età sì perché nella scorsa
partita a vento li può fare
abbiamo un momento le camere vediamo che
succede
ho visto male
il suo animaletto che scappa aiuto o
quasi finita la stessa avvicinando
quando mi nascondo mi nascondo foto ok
ia libera quella rossa catalana samb
tasche troppo lunga nel frattempo aveva
eliminato qualcun altro no è solo una
task ed è quella della benzina nasconde
mi ha fatto qua ma non mi nascondo qua
nessuno ho trovato il più povero
corpicino vediamo quanti più menez
rimangono rimangono tu mi raccomando lei
attento ormai il nas con lo so 4 creme
rimangono allora seguiamo l'impostore
vediamo un po dovere non doversi ok ora
è andato invece in mad bay so io ti dico
tutti i passaggi che
e allora in un vento da torino e francia
è in aumento ma lavitola senta sempre
non seguono per sapere se vi devo
spostare anch'io però il rennes al
reattore sta cercando qualcun altro
entrato in un vento tra sfida e
velocissimo questore io sto facendo qui
domani
pensavamo in due sono io il rosso fa
sopra ma chi è che non ha finito le
tacco ciò che già le new nota in tutta
la luce al cuore impostore non c'è una
fan hanno perso di portare no no no no
no è salvato scappando pastor ha visto
giallo sta rincorrendo lo sta
rincorrendo no è riuscito a salvarsi
quanti crimini mancano forse solo due
io sono con rosso quindi siamo almeno
due più quello di che abbiamo visto
scappare al giallo quindi tre almeno 38
o meno dalla reggina è stato eliminato
l'imposta
vedo uno giallo giallo riportato
arancione ne rimangono solo due il che
vuol dire che è probabilmente il bottone
vincerà perché di barton eliminarne uno
e avrà vinto l'asta l'imposta sta
inseguendo rosso o no lasciamo scappare
giallo casa lo vorrebbe entrambi
ok prossima partita o anche aumentato la
velocità in base alla vostra richiesta
vediamo un po più belle d'italia stato
sbattuto fuori perché era così sono
momento che succede sono diecimila
persone che provano entrare quindi non è
riuscito a entrare
vediamo chi è l'impostore è un problema
l'impostore non si sta dichiarando
quindi non sta seguendo le regole
no non è possibile importare da vedere
chi è altrimenti non possiamo giocare
sono io dice bianco più male
sembra che devo pattinando sicuramente
sarà più facile scappare però anche
l'impostore s le parole quindi sarà più
facile anche per lui prende andiamo
subito a parole inoltre tasti o no
l'impostore è già eliminato qualcuno
paura che piange la pasta al pesto che
rendono il mio manga perché i favorevoli
motivate mettere trovato poi con questa
modalità veloce l'impostore ride dice
bene speriamo questa volta che
completino le tasse dai due volte già
iniziati un pò storia bianco
no anzi o meno dai tassi non stanno
completando le tac attento potrebbe
essere poco attento dimenticato che noi
dobbiamo anche lui doveva trovare nel
partito né possiamo vedere tutti dove
sono nato
sto andando a prenderlo l'uomo per un
pelo alla scampata lì ci sia anche se
l'essere scorso qui l'impostore sta
guardando le camere per scoprire dove
sono
no sta aperto dove si è nascosta
impostore sta seriamente impazzendo sta
andando da una parte all'altra per
l'affidamento 6 inseguendolo se
inseguendo scappa scappa prima volta
sarà in vigore
prossima partita con tre impostori
pronti sarà una cosa devastante
andiamo subito a creme pure giallo il
secondo celeste ok vi angelo se lette
giallo era impossibile
già mi sono dimenticato anche colore
bianco sono troppi aiutarlo andiamoci
coordinato dei blu blu blu e io mi
rifarò più che no no
[Applauso]
i minori nati pregio come la polpetta
sfigato che scappare
io ho talmente tante che non resta
concentrato a dare una mano alle tasche
che cosa è questa ok devo fare la mia
parte preferita
quando si si non posso che l'ultima
partita è tornato anche vita oggi
viviamo impostori bigliani diamo a
cercare le persone note lo possiamo dire
aprire la stessa è talmente emozionata
di essere impostore che mi sono
dimenticato che non può dirlo nelle
emergenze in più sto dicendo io radar
celeste gianna importare perfetto poi
tra l'altro conosciamo tutti i punti
dove dove ci si può nascondere qui era
troppo divertente allora qualcuno è
scappato palo vediamo vediamo io vi sto
arrivando
[Applauso]
è troppo divertente giocare anche come
la persona che deve trovare un match che
si nascondo che poi è strano che siamo
capitati conquistare assieme chi è
questo viola via non scappate non mi
faccio niente ma quanto sei doverosi e
scappare non c'è nessuno sarebbe
scappato velocissimi eliminata bianca
che si nascondeva al bayern vediamo se
c'è qualcuno che si nasconde che
allungano il tempo per niente io
purtroppo aspettare secondo un altro
altrimenti se erano proprio tattico
l'acquaforte neretini già eliminati due
io nessuno in zona nera sta scappando
allora se lei
no ce l'ha e tempo per come me ha
portato il corpo ha ora un altro timer
di 20 secondi non va bene è troppo
divertente giocare ma anche dei tori che
vai a cercare troppo da rete mancano
ancora quattro ritirare o tre insomma
siamo passati venti secondi di tempo
comunque la cosa divertente di essere
impostore che devo trovare voi al futuro
e non avere la paura di essere già lo
sapete che dura un impostore quindi
velocemente eliminare tutti allora
guardiamo le camere di sicurezza per
vedere dove si nascondono immediate sono
il panno rosso celeste che sta ridando 4
giu sta qua
dovrebbero da una mina coletto
bravissimo come tra velocissima allora
il mio obiettivo è trovare d'italia si
prende allora io impostore continuate a
chiedervi se sono la vera vita
per sapere se sono la vera star commesso
mi state scrivendo dirottare ogni giorno
che si sono persone che si stanno
chiudendo me so monga
l'unico modo per sapere se sono
realmente io è se il co.di sia stato
pubblicato sul mio profilo instagram
quello ufficiale anita storie school
theron è stato pubblicato né
probabilmente non sono io perché io
gioco solamente pubblicando il
copriletto quindi state attenti a non
farvi prendere in giro da altre false
animati versetti numeri 13 attore mi ha
fatto venire alla roma
ma chi ha chiamato un emergency meeting
qualcuno che vada majesty miti che ha
detto che l'ha fatto perché jiabao
grazie mille avrebbe perso marcarino
però così le altre persone non riescono
a giocare bene e ovviamente si scorsi
seguite sempre le regole mi raccomando
sarà l'ultima partita abbiamo provato a
fare un'altra partita ma c'era qualcuno
che chiamato l'emergency meeting per
dire impostori e poi non ha mai skipass
siamo rimasti tipo prossimi minuti
bloccati
non so perché non c'era neanche il timer
che finiva per giorni abbiamo provato
tutti quanti a chi carla rocchi ma non
funzionava sarà qualcosa di strano c'è
messi però abbiamo dovuto interrompere
pure stato super di potere giocare con
voi su propri destini commenti il minuto
che vi ha fatto io gli darei lasciate un
bel mi piace meraviglia 4 che a salire
poi cliccare per vedere inoltre altri
video in casa su quella che preferite
video